chaos in porto prince
haiti is a country without a functioning
government its economies collapsed and
protesters are demanding prime minister
ariel omrie step down
haitian people will demonstrate with our
plates and spoons and blankets and
pillows in front of ariel henry's house
to ask him to resign because hunger and
insecurity are killing us all
during the demonstrations a man was shot
and killed witnesses say the attacker
fled in a car
gang violence has surged since the
assassination of president giovanna
mwasi last year his successor enjoys
support from the international community
but has been criticized for saying he
has no plans to step down until
elections are held
we live in a society where people can't
afford to eat and drink if conditions
for the most vulnerable people here
don't improve we will stay on the
streets we have a different vision for
the country one where young people can
thrive
haiti is still struggling to recover
from a magnitude 7.2 earthquake that
destroyed the southern tip of the
peninsula a year ago
crippling economic conditions are likely
to worsen as the political crisis drags
on
there's gas shortages there's severe
criminality with kidnappings and gang
violence uh
massacres over the last few weeks um and
therefore the government so far has been
uh rather weak in its responses and
hasn't been able to uh to address these
uh realities that are affecting daily
lives for haiti
critics of the prime minister have vowed
to continue to protest until they get
the change they say haiti needs
victoria gatenbee al jazeera